[Music]
this is the port of savannah in georgia
the second largest port on the east
coast this map shows ship locations
tracked by the company marine traffic on
august 19th there was a backup of about
30 container ships similar backlogs have
formed at the ports in new york and
houston this is important because it
makes life difficult for businesses
particularly small businesses and it's
also important because it helps to keep
the cost of shipping goods high which
contributes to inflation so how did this
backlog happen and what's being done to
relieve the congestion
to understand what's happening today on
the east and gulf coast you have to go
all the way back to the beginning of the
pandemic when there was first a massive
decrease in the number of goods moving
around the world and then an enormous
increase of flood of imports that really
hasn't stopped for the last two years
the worst bottlenecks at u.s ports have
been concentrated at the ports of los
angeles and long beach in southern
california where earlier this year there
was a backup of more than 100 container
ships this year cargo growth has slowed
at the southern california ports the
main u.s gateway for goods imported from
asia but volumes headed into the country
through the east and gulf coasts have
kept rising so retailers and
manufacturers had a really really
difficult time in 2021 getting all of
the goods and the widgets that they
needed in order to get products to the
stores they were so concerned at the
start of this year that they would see
similar delays to the ones that they saw
last year that they both ordered earlier
than they normally would and they
ordered more than they normally would
and because retailers and manufacturers
were worried about the ports on the west
coast they diverted cargo to the ports
at new york houston and savannah another
reason that shippers are diverting cargo
from the west coast this year is because
there are labor talks between the union
that represents about 22 000 dock
workers at all of the ports along the
west coast historically those talks have
been contentious and there have been
work slowdowns that have caused
significant delays to cargo
during the first five months of the year
the volume of loaded containers reaching
the port of new york and new jersey rose
more than 12 percent from the comparable
period of 2021 according to the pacific
merchant shipping association the
inbound volume at port houston jumped 24
in that period the impact of the
congestion at these eastern gulf coast
ports is being felt both by companies
that are trying to import goods into the
country as well as by exporters cargo
handling terminals at the ports are so
full that they load and unload ships
more slowly causing backups at sea on
land truckers can't return empty boxes
so their yards fill up with containers
sitting atop trailers the port of new
york and new jersey is clogged with
about 200 000 empty containers waiting
to be picked up by ocean carriers at the
houston port import boxes are sitting an
average of six to seven days twice as
long as usual this isn't so much a
failure of the port and its operations
it's more an illustration of what
happens when ports become so overwhelmed
with cargo at the end of the day the
ports only have a finite amount of space
but port officials say they are taking
steps to try to relieve the congestion
many of them have found additional land
either within their own ports or outside
of them where they can store extra
containers and free up a little bit of
space so that they can move boxes on and
off ships more efficiently other
officials have talked about charging
ocean carriers for empty containers that
spend too long at the port just like the
ports on the west coast and particularly
in southern california there's very
little in the short term that they can
do to alleviate the problem for example
dredging channels and installing new
cranes those kinds of improvements can
take years but shipping officials say a
slowdown in cargos might be on the
horizon because many importers brought
goods in early and because there are
significant signs of a slowdown in
consumer spending
some of the shipping industry executives
and officials that i spoke to said that
they expect this year's peak shipping
season which we're currently in the
middle of
is expected to be a lot softer than it
normally is some industry officials are
hopeful that in the weeks and months
ahead the amount of congestion will
reduce and the bottlenecks will begin to
subside at least a little bit